So, let's look at the solution to our
MOVZ/MOVN QUIZ. We have this code. And we want
to do if conversion of it, so that we
get a branch-free code that does the same work.
If conversion amounts to doing the work of
both paths, both the not-taken and the taken paths.
And then selecting between the two and correcting the
results so that only one of them is active.
So, what we have done is, these two
instructions are already doing the work of the
not-taken path. Is just that instead of in
R2, which would permanently modify R2, we're putting the
result in R4 and here the taken path R3 and 1 are added, then we put the result
in R5 instead of R3. So what now needs to happen is, if this was
the correct path to take, then R2 should get the result
of R4. Otherwise, R3 should get the result from R5.
This is a branch on equal 0, R1. So
if R1 is not equal 0, meaning
MOVN on R1 used as a condition. We're going to be moving R4 into R2.
If the branch is branching, then R1 is zero, and in that case
we want to be moving R5 into R3. And this is our if converted
code that has four instructions worth of work, but no branches in them.
In contrast, the original code has three instructions
worth of work, in this path, and two instructions
worth of work in this path. But, it
has this branch that might be difficult to predict.